a liberal is supposed to be somebody
who's anti-authoritarian
a liberal is supposed to be somebody
who's for the people is for freedom for
freedom of speech uh neoliberals are the
exact opposite they're for censorship
they're against workers they're against
unions they're uh for the corporations i
mean to me that that's what i think of
maybe i'm wrong i'm not the smartest guy
in the world i'm not an academic that's
for sure i'm also a comedian a nightclub
comedian entertaining drunks my whole
career and then uh turns out the news is
so shitty it's so corrupted in the
united states that i can do a way better
job than people who get millions and
millions of dollars to do the news the
news is just propaganda in the united
states 100 percent
and the terror and
at the moment joe rogan seems to be
fighting his own personal battle against
them
by platforming all the people you know
who have their accounts taken down etc
etc
how long can this go on for jimmy
because a populist and its citizens that
no longer have faith in the media shows
that society is broken as far as i'm
concerned that's right and that's why
joe rogan gets 11 million downloads per
podcast and cnn gets less than a million
people watching theirs so i mean he's
just destroying them and why
because he's not propaganda joe rogan is
an honest
uh actor and people sense it and uh he
reaches across the aisle he you know he
endorsed uh bernie sanders but they want
to make him seem like he's a crazy right
winger because that's what a cult does
and the democratic party is a cult and
look what happened to sarah silverman
look what happened to pat and oswald
sarah silverman criticized an msnbc news
reader for lying and she did lie and she
was me and the news reader was
african-american she was immediately
pilloried as a racist as a person you
would never say that to a white woman
and she had to apologize
she had to apologize for criticizing a
news person for lying
[Music]
she goes i'm sorry
she goes i didn't i don't want any
trouble
and they did the same thing for me and i
said guess what i'm gonna take some
[ __ ] trouble i'm not gonna knuckle
under to the establishment i'll take the
trouble i'm gonna tell the truth and
when a news person's lying i'm not gonna
go along with the [ __ ] lie and i'm
not gonna go along with the smear after
i call out their lie and that's what
they did look what pat oswalt did pat
also took a picture with dave chappelle
he had he had to [ __ ] have him do a
maya culpa because he took a picture
with somebody
or he's out of the cult
that's it sarah silverman you're out of
the cold pat nozzle you're out of the
cult and they will do anything to stay
in the cold
isn't that the problem jimmy they do
anything to stay in the cult yes when
actually people like us people like you
people like joe rogan will say no
[ __ ] you and that means that we stand up
and they become less powerful but the
people who capitulate just make them
more powerful
yes and that's sad and i you know i
sympathize with them what are they good
what are they supposed to do not work in
show business anymore they're in a tough
spot i under i you know i blame the
culture i don't blame them but joe
rogan's kicking everyone's ass and he's
not gonna stop
and people aren't gonna you know i just
saw so they had these fake doctors 250
doctors signed a a letter to spotify
saying you should have someone on to
counter joe rogan's misinformation
meanwhile mainstream news had been lying
about covet at the top of their lungs
for [ __ ] two straight years and they
lie about everything but they want to
but on joe rogan it's a it's dangerous
because he has a counter narrative to
their [ __ ] they want him to bring
out hey why don't you make msnbc and cnn
bring on dr robert malone why don't you
ever [ __ ] make that why don't you
ever make that demand that nbc and cbs
they they have to have balance no one
ever f they never brought on anybody to
debunk russiagate they never brought on
anybody they had a counter narrative to
covet mandates vaccines none of it they
have to go on joe rogan's show and by
the way joe rogan i've i heard i don't
know how accurate this is but i heard
that his uh interview with dr robert
malone got 40 million downloads so by
trying to censor him they again it had
what they call the streisand effect
which is when you try to when you try to
hide something and censor it and silence
it you just get more attention to it and
uh more people see it and that's exactly
what happened with dr robert malone on
joe rogan's show and now they want joe
rogan and spotify to have balance nobody
else has [ __ ] ballots in the news
media and the biggest purveyor of
misinformation is the esta first is the
government and then the second one is
the establishment news media joe rogan's
not the problem joe rogan is the
antidote to the problem
well this is why i said recently even
though i do think both peter mccullough
and malone probably are wrong on a lot
of things in my opinion now i'm not a
medic but i do think that
i still respect joe for having them on
uh and the reason i say that is to me
the effects of this sort of censorship
where essentially uh the big tech
companies now decide what the truth is
is far worse than someone going on a
podcast and saying some things that may
later turn out to be medical
misinformation i just that's how i feel
and the reason i say this is i remember
the day i woke up and i saw the the new
york post had posted an article about
hunter biden
and then i saw
that every single big tech company this
is on the eve of a pivotal election in
your country jimmy
and every big tech company just went no
you're not sharing this story it's
russian disinformation and let's be
let's call it what it is you know people
can talk about election interference and
i'm sure it happens both ways but that
was blatant election interference and
these people are now claiming that they
know what the truth is [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
and that's why i love what joe is doing
even though i think some of the things
that these guests are saying are wrong
because someone needs to push back
against this [ __ ] the government is
always lying the cdc and the fda are the
fda gets 70 of its budget from big
pharma when they have to approve a drug
or a vaccine it's they're they're not an
independent organization and when donald
trump was president uh guess what every
democrat was saying the same thing that
i don't trust the pr
governor cuomo in new york said i don't
trust the process and i don't trust the
fda
i do want to ask you about that
especially as it pertains to the vaccine
we saw dr fauci last night say that he
trusts the experts at the fbi at the fda
how confident are you in the approval
process of the fda right now
well first uh how confident am i uh i'm
not that confident but my opinion
doesn't matter i don't believe the
american people are that confident
you're going to say to the american
people now here's a vaccine it was new
it was done quickly but trust this
federal administration and their health
administration that it's safe
and
we're not 100 sure of the consequences i
think it's going to be a very skeptical
american public about taking the vaccine
and they should be
he was then they wanted him to be the
next democratic president before he got
uh kicked out of office for killing all
those old people
and sexually harassing everyone and
joe biden said he was vaccine hesitant
kamala harris said she wouldn't take the
bat they all said a version of this
and then all of a sudden joe biden
becomes president now they completely
flip their tune and i'm supposed to
believe them joe biden's a [ __ ]
pathological liar he's a bigger lie he's
just as big a liar as trump and uh i've
got the receipts to prove it the guy's
uh and he's demented and they're lying
to us that this guy isn't demented and
i'm supposed to believe them [ __ ] you
fauci's a criminal he should be in jail
there's a movie called the dallas buyers
club which stars matthew mcconaughey and
it's just
how the uh the government fauci [ __ ]
over aids patients by keeping drugs that
could help them away just like they did
with covent
[Music]